[Musique]
peut-être que tu met un petit coup de
peinture
moi je voulais faire buffalo maul tu
vois ni western immole rêvant les
banques ont passé des gens très bon ces
fonds pourraient tenir pour dit garcia
fons à la voix d'or
je suis un boulot là pour le westin
paris vendôme est aujourd'hui bel c'est
chic
je crois que sa mère est de toulouse
alors aidé à mettre des frites serait le
roi des belges seraient parés de prière
et nourris de même jouer à je regrette
qu'elle reçoit écoute moi bien mon petit
bonhomme tu m'a rappelé que tu gardes
dire immédiatement accepté d'être notre
habitude mais vous voyez pas dexter
cheval blanc ah oui tout à fait votre
adresse alors pourquoi tu touches
et qui toi je sais pas comment ça se
passe en belgique 1 mais en france
l'usurpation d'identité ça va chercher
dans les cinq ans de prison
je vais en être exclu qu'on avait volé
des bijoux du concierge d'hôtel sa
chaussette soba rang qu bon secousses et
de laurent blanc
l'histoire et dans l'océan 11 avec
george clooney patino ça ne marchera
jamais personne ne pas tuer ma femme je
n'ai pas assez pleine je voudrais qu
elle m'apprend tu vas bien apprendre à
lire tu sais pourquoi les belges leif
les vieux mais sur de vieux murs
s'effritent
non tu peux paris ce qui vous fait rire
nous fait pas rire j'ai fait des pas
perdus et on veut c te retrouves tu fais
du café si tu le retrouves à partir de
maintenant tu es en deuil
enfin c'est clair
mais pour t'écoute j'ai très envie de
mousse et des mois dans la bière une
fois qu'on gagne